une plante aromatique qui donne bonne
mine ce romarin historique et cultivé au
potager du roi et depuis un mois ils se
retrouvent dans trois produits de beauté
d'un couple versailles et ils étaient
utilisés d'abord par charles 5 et louis
xiv à la fois pour donc comme au
médicinales qui était à la fois but est
à la fois donc utilisé sur les plaies
pour les désinfecter et puis plus tard
par madame de sévigné qui ont utilisé à
la fois pour cent mètres sur le visage
comme aux cosmétiques cette fois à la
fois aux 6% parfumé et plus tard c'est
jean louis fargue on le parfumeur de
marie antoinette qui revisite à l'eau la
reine de hongrie qui est donc un
hydrolat de romarin pour en faire un
parfum un projet né en juillet 2016
grâce à un partenariat avec le potager
du roi et l'école nationale supérieure
du paysage un an et demi de recherche et
de développement
je suis pharmacien issus de l'industrie
pharmaceutique et je me disais tous les
jours en passant ici dix ans le potager
du roi est un espace naturel vraiment
remarquable qui contiennent diversité
botanique d'une haute qualité et
comment ça se fait que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui personne n'est plus utilisé
dans la fabrication de produits
cosmétiques les produits de la jeune
marque sont pour le moment disponibles
dans six points de vente versailles et
et parisiens charles cracco et sa
compagne pensent déjà à leur prochaine
création autour du concombre blanc de
bonneuil